I started playing guitar when I was 12
or 13 the company's full of musicians
well Fender Musical Instruments has been
around since 1946 we're the world's
largest producer of guitars and
amplifiers from the 1950s and the birth
of rock and roll to today artists like
John Mayer Eric Clapton Keith Urban Jimi
Hendrix they've all held a Fender
instrument everything is just so classic
and original that everybody uses
everybody's first guitar it kind of
triggers all these memories
it's a Fender guitar this building
produces the quintessential fender
product guitars are interesting there
aren't a lot of industries where
globally an american-made product is the
most premier and prestigious highly
sought after aspirational product but
Fender guitars are
people will save years to be able to
afford them a USA made Fender guitar
there's no question that sometimes
running a business in California is
challenging there's a lot of regulatory
issues but you know what we have so much
pride in our heritage we have so much
pride in our roots here
we've always been a Southern California
company and we're not going anywhere
soon the two main components of the
guitar are the body and the neck and so
each of those start off as raw pieces of
wood and they go through a wood milling
process this is a three piece spread of
ash from the southeastern United States
these are the samples that we use to
make sure that we have the shape of the
neck exactly right here's the guy might
have heard of him before if it's a
thousandth of an inch off some of these
guys comes down it still kind of gives
me chills to come through here and see
some of the machines and use for you
know 50 60 years it goes into paint it
goes through a curing process this is
where it really all comes together now
we start dressing the frets putting the
electronics in and then it goes over and
it's packaged ready to go out to the
next rock star
you
you